[muzică]
Nu mi dau seama dacă la cea din stânga e
trăsătură sau este o mizerie pe fir.
Uitați vă și voi.
Stânga de tot.
A tot făcut așa.
Mă gândesc că
poate am linebind uri ceva. Poate sunt
peștii pe acolo. Dau un fir
și
eu văd semnalizările pe vârf. Uite și
asta la fel face.
Cred eu că astea două le am dat pe
cioată și astea puțin din dreapta. Nu m
am orientat eu foarte bine
când m am pus pe locul de pescuit și
pe cele din dreapta n am văzut nimic. N
am văzut niciun linebind, nimic, nicio
mișcare și mă gândesc că astea două le
am dat pe ciudată acolo unde am văzut
peștii. Hai să vedem dacă
dacă mușcă vreunul.
Fiind Fiind apa rece,
mă gândesc că ei sunt destul de apatici.
Uite, asta pare trăsătură, nu pare Nu
pare mizerie pe fir, că e ciupitură.
Nici nu știu.
Oricum îmi zicea Harry. Hari a prins,
ier pești a prins și astăzi.
Și î zicea că trăsăturile au fost destul
de violente, adică la fel ca vara când a
luat o, s a lăsat pe ea.
Așa că nu știu ce să zic. Hai să vedem.
Primul pește, dragi pescari,
dar e parcat.
Ha, e direct în ciudată.
Nici nu știu dacă mai e.
Ba da, da, da, da. Este, este. Hai,
poate este de acolo.
Deci am dat eu fix în ciată. Ar trebui
să dau un pic mai spre mine pentru că am
dat prea Am dat în ea, cred sau aproape
de ea pentru că n a avut nu și a luat
fir. Efectiv a urcat cu a urcat cu
momitorul. S a dus un pic în stânga. Ia
să vedem. Hai, poate iese de acolo
singur.
Nici nu l mai simt că ar fi acolo.
Deci nu l mai simt. E bine că am avut o
trăsătură. O să încerc să dau un pic mai
aproape de mine. Cred că și celelalte le
am. Le am tot în ciată. Nu mi am luat
bine reperul. V am zis. Nu mi am luat
bine reperul distanța și na.
Asta e. Hai să l
încerc să l vedem dacă
Bun. Am avut prima trăsătură, deci e
bine aici. Nu mai știu ce am avut.
Haideți să vă arăt nada de pe momitor
cum s a făcut.
Este nada ediție, ediție specială
la care am adăugat pelete de 2 mm de la
noi din portofoliu. Da. Și cam așa s a
făcut. Cred că are vreo 25 de minute în
apă. Și aici cred că am avut o peletă de
nu mai știu căpșună.
Căpșună sau s sau secrit aroma de 10 mm.
Oricum îi schimb cârligul și dau din
nou. Uitați cârligul cum e.
Da, am pus peleta pe spin de data asta.
Peletele de 10 mm am observat că pot să
le pun pe spin.
Am plecat un pește de sub mine.
Peletele de 10 am observat că pot să le
pun pe spin și cele de 15 pe firul de
păr.
Bun, hai, gata cu vorba, schimb cârligul
și lansez din nou. O să lansez un pic
mai aproape. Așa arată după 40 de minute
de stat în apă
pe
apă de 7°.
peleta care s a activat foarte bine și
nada. Nada oricum nu am umectat o prea
mult și nu am strâns o prea tare.
Efectiv am vrut să se desfacă mai
repede. Deci am dat mai puțină apă.
Deci, bă băieți, deci jur, deci nu o să
vă vină să credeți.
Deci n am rămit la mine. Uitați vă și
voi ce am scos de pe fundul apei.
Păi și cum să mai prindem noi peșt, mă?
Băieți, dacă pe fundul apei, în Delta
Dunării avem așa ceva, care erau șansele
să scot eu așa ceva la cârlig.
Voi vă dați seama? Deci uitați vă și
voi. Râmă de pământ direct din apă. Da.
E scoasă de aici din fața mea. Bună
dimineața, dragi pescari. Suntem din nou
în Delta Dunării. Este prima partidă pe
anul acesta. Este o partidă super
scurtă. Eu am avut ceva treabă la Tulcea
ieri și am zis că dacă tot ajung la
Tulcea, nu n aș avea cum să rezist fără
să bag și eu bățul în baltă. Am ajuns
ieri pe la ora 2:00. M am întâlnit cu
Harry mai mult, am venit, na, și ăsta a
fost un factor ca să vin la Mila la 23.
Hari era aici și am zis să vin să
pescuiesc cu el și să l salut. Am ajuns
ieri pe la ora 2:00. Am stat un pic cu
Hari, oră, oră și un pic cât am vorbit,
ne am întâlnit pe apă, după care am
pescuit pe acest loc timp de două ore.
Am avut o trăsătură, un pește care a
plecat cu a plecat cu montura și s a dus
direct în ciată.
Iar acum
am ajuns de 10 minute, am lansat
lansetele. Nu avem cum să ne ducem mai
departe de atât. Suntem pe lângă Mila 23
și este ceață și n avem cum să ieșim pe
lacuri, să ne ducem pe alte canale și
așa mai departe pentru că, na, e ceață
și este periculos. Ce s a întâmplat
ieri?
Am venit, am găsit o ciată, am găsit
peștele care se plimba.
Era cumva între
mal și cioată, adică între mine și
cioată. Eu acum sunt ancorat la mal în
stuf și peștele era cumva între noi, se
plimba.
După ce am avut, după ce am lansat
lansetele, am început să am foarte multe
line bite uri. Prima dată am crezut că
vine mizerie pe apă.
După care am scos o lansetă și mi am dat
seama că nu am nimic pe fire și atunci
atunci am zis că este pește. Deci,
practic, peștele se plimba se plimba
prin jurul
monturii, lua firul și atunci avea multe
semnalizări pe vârf. Oricum o să vă arăt
pe filmare pentru că am filmat și ieri
un pic. După ce am avut trăsătura și
peștele a intrat în ciată, efectiv, mă
scuzați un pic, îmi sună telefonul.
Este Narcis. Narcis, dacă vezi dacă vezi
clipul ăsta, să știi că m ai întrerupt.
După ce am avut trăsătura, efectiv
peștele a dispărut din fața mea. N am
mai avut după aia nici măcar un lineb,
nici măcar o trăsătură și am zis hai să
văd ce se întâmplă. După care am ieșit
cu barca, dar deja era prea târziu și mi
am dat seama că peștele era deja
pe partea cealaltă de cioată. Era între
cioată și șenal.
cumva era pe apă un pic mai adâncă. Da.
Deci se mutați pe partea cealaltă. Ce
vreau să zic cu lucrul acesta și
probabil că o să spuneți că sunt nebun
pentru că țin cont de toate de toate
lucrurile astea că vorba aia, bă dacă
mănâncă trebuie să iasă din ceată să
vină să ți caute montura, trebuie să
ținem cont că apa este foarte rece. Deci
cam băgam una dimineață în apă efectiv
mi a înghețat instant. Da. Nu m am uitat
pe sonar, dar din aproximațiile mele
cred că are apa maxim 6°.
Peștele este foarte mofturos, este
apatic, este strâns pe cioă, am văzut
mult pește în cioată.
El efectiv nu caută mâncare. Da, deci
este perioada din an în care noi trebuie
să i dăm cu plumul în cap dacă vrem să
prindem pește. Efectiv cum am avut pește
în față într o oră am avut trăsătură, de
fapt în 40 de minute am avut trăsătură
cât el s a plimbat pe acolo, cât a stat
pe acolo. Narcis insistă.
Și
după aia a dispărut. Da, deci el nu a
venit să se hrănească. Orice am face noi
în perioada asta, foarte slabe șansele
ca el să se hrănească, dar pe apă atât
de atât de rece. Mă rog, asta este
părerea mea. Acuma fiecare pescar cu
părerea lui.
În general, în partide de iarnă, în
partide de genul acesta, cum a fost și
cea din decembrie, am observat că
funcționează foarte bine tehnica în care
te muți foarte des. Ai prins un pește
doi maxim de pe un loc, după care te ai
mutat. Eu data trecută pe Litcov
am observat am observat lucrul ăsta și
chiar asta am pus în practică, dar am
mai avut doar o zi de pescui pe Litcov
și atunci na, asta e, am prins câțiva
pești nu am putut să fac, nu știu, două
trei zile la rând. Deci prindeam un
pește, doi de pe un loc, poate chiar
trei, dar bine trei când am prins trei
erau ciortani, erau micuți, după care mă
muta. Da.
Cred eu că se și sperie repede. Ieri
când când sondam pe lângă pe lângă
cioată am văzut cum în momentul în care
am băgat am băgat motorul în viteză,
știți că face clancul acela, am văzut
cum peștii s au speriat de pe ciozonul
în care trebuie să i dăm efectiv cu
plumbul în cap și dacă avem noroc să
nimerim să i dăm cu plumbul în cap, o să
prindem și pește. Asta o să încerc să
fac astăzi, să i dau cu plumbul în cap.
Vă spun sincer, locul unde sunt acuma nu
prea îmi place pentru că nu pot să
abordez niciodată așa cum vreau eu.
N am reușit să mi iau reperele foarte
bine. Este stuf și stânga și dreapta.
Este foarte greu să ți iei repere pe
stuf ca să vezi exact unde este cioata
și la ce distanță. Cel puțin mie îmi
este greu să îmi iau repere. Acum, pe
perioada asta, aș prefera un canal mai
îngust, un canal unde pot să poate să l
lansez și pe sub mână, să dau să mă
ancurez cât mai aproape de ceată, ca să
fiu sigur că dau efectiv lângă ea. Da,
lângă ea sau poate chiar în ea. Poate
chiar să mă pun pe ea și să bag cu
firele de 0,55 să bag mitobitor în în
cioată și să fac tehnica aia care pe
care. Bun, cam asta este despre partidă.
Despre partida asta. Vă spuneam că este
o partidă super scurtă. Eu astăzi o să
plec. Deci pescuiesc astăzi, nu știu,
poate până la ora 2:00 2:30, maxim 3:00.
Trebuie să sun și la parcarea de băr, să
văd până la ce oră, până la ce oră poate
să mă scoată din apă. După care o să
plec acasă, dar o să urmez o altă
partidă cu Mihai Manea pe data de 19.
Mergem la GFT. Ia, aici am avut ori un
line bite, ori ori o trăsătură. Nu știu
dacă s a văzut pe cameră.
Bun, nada pescuiesc este noua nadă,
ediție specială.
O să vă mai arăt și astăzi cum se cum se
vede pe momitor.
Am combinat o cu peletele de 2 mm. Nu am
pelete de 5 și de 3 mm și atunci am luat
peletele de 2 mm. Iar la cârlig
am scos doar căpșună și usturoi de 10
mm. Ieri mi a venit trăsătura pe
pe De fapt, scuze, am secret aroma și
căpșună. Ă, ieri mi a venit trăsătura pe
Secret Aroma.
Bun, astea fiind spuse, mai vorbim pe în
cursul partidei. Prin clipurile pe care
le fac, încerc să dau cât mai multe
informații, așa cum reușesc să le explic
sau așa cum le am eu în cap. informații
pe care le adun de la pescari,
informații pe care le am dobândit în
partidele mele de pescuit pentru că sunt
sau cel puțin și eu am fost la început
și îmi aduc aminte cât de mult aveam
nevoie de informații. De câte ori mă
uitam la un clip, de exemplu, de al lui
Marian de la GFT, ca să văd cum face, ce
face, cum merge cu barca, cum se
ancorează, tot felul de lucruri care, mă
rog, întrebări la care eu nu aveam
răspuns pe vremea respectivă și încerc
în clipurile mele să fac același lucru
pentru că și eu am fost la început și
știu că este greu să dau cât mai multe
informații și mai vreau să spun ceva
despre partida asta. Ăă probabil că
printre voi cei care vă uitați sunt și
pescari începători, sunt pescari care
poate vor să se apuce sau să meargă în
Delta Dunării.
Ă Deci, vreau vreau să nu știu să
subliniez foarte mult chestia asta cu
localizarea peștelui, mai ales în
anotimpul în anotimpul rece. Localizarea
este, să zic, cu totul diferit față de
vară. Dacă vara, să zicem că găsim
peștii pe o cioată sau în jurul unei
cioate sau găsim un prag, găsim o zonă,
o zonă de interes pentru pește, vara el
se plimbă, deci el efectiv caută
mâncare. Vara se se plimbă, se duce,
vine se duce pe șenal vine la praguri,
se hrănește pe praguri, iese din ciată,
se duce la altă ciată, se întoarce. Da.
În anotimpul rece, cel puțin în perioada
în care eu sunt acum, martie, dar este
foarte frig.
Peștii stau cantonați, efectiv stau
cantonați pe pe cioate, cel puțin pe
zona unde eu sunt acum. Da, poate că
dacă mergem pe o altă zonă s ar putea să
vedem un comportament diferit al
peștelui. Nu știu să vă spun ce i dă
acest comportament peștelui, că încă
avem și noi întrebări la care nu avem
răspuns. Eu cel puțin am întrebări la
care nu am răspuns. Mi s a întâmplat de
multe ori să văd pe două locuri
diferite, de fapt pe două canale
diferite, comportament diferit al
peștelui. Și dacă mă întrebați de unde
știu comportamentul, îl știu cu sonarul.
Pentru că eu studiez foarte mult
sonarul. Adică îmi place să stau când
îmi aleg un loc de pescuit, stau minim
10, 15, 20 de minute. Bine, în funcție
de deloc, dacă î cunosc foarte bine sau
m pescuit pe el, nu mai stau atât de
mult. Doar mă uit să văd dacă e pește,
pentru că știu deja unde să arunc. Și mă
uit doar un pic la comportamentul
peștelui, să vezi să văd ce face.
Deci ce este foarte important în
perioada asta este să îi dăm cu plumbul
în cap. Deci eu am ajuns la concluzia să
i dăm, vorba aia, să i dăm cu plumbul în
cap, efectiv să să i dăm acolo unde este
el, unde este unde este densitate mare
de pește. Așa avem șanse să prindem
pește. Sunt pescari care au noroc, care
se duc. Eu de obicei nu prea am noroc la
pescuit, nu știu de ce. Eu trebuie să
muncesc ca să prind pește. Sunt pescari
care se duc, se pun pe o ciată și
efectiv i dau cu plumbul în cap și încep
să scoată încep să scoată pește. Dar în
momentul de față, în perioadele astea,
nu funcționează nădirea.
Nadele trebuie să fie, Eu încerc să fac
nadele, să nu le fac să seze atât de
tare ca să se desfacă relativ repede, să
facă o dâră în speranța în care peștii
dacă Adică eu am omitorul aici, da?
Curentul îmi ia nada și îmi face o dâră
de nadă, da?
Iar peștii dacă ies din ciată și vin vin
un pic spre mal sau vin din din aval și
urcă în amonte, dacă găsesc dâra aceea,
pentru că este o nadă fină, bine, o nadă
fină în comparație cu bilele, da? Este o
nadă grosieră de particule mari. ăă dacă
va va găsi chestia aia, sper eu și ăă
sper că asta se întâmplă, să găsească și
să vină pe pe dâra de nadă să să caute
sursa. Da, iar când el caută sursa,
atunci găsește și cârligul nostru. Cam
asta este pescuitul la monitoare și cam
asta este ce poți să faci. Harry a făcut
nădire i el și alalte dar nu i a răspuns
la nădire și aici am făcut a făcut
nădire el. Mi a mi a aruncat mi a
aruncat bile pentru că eu n am nu mi am
luat bile la mine și ne a răspuns la
bile peștele. Adică e clar că nu a ieșit
din niciodată ca să caute bilele și după
aia să înceapă să se hrănească ca vara.
Da. Vara îl scoți din ciooată sau îl
scoți de din locurile unde sunt. Îi
arunci bile pe lângă, el vine, ia o
bilă, ia două bile, ia trei bile și după
care începe să le caute. Da. Acum
pescuitul este complet diferit. Este
pescuitul în care este perioada în care
dacă prinzi trei patru pești este foarte
foarte bine și este perioada în care
este posibil să nu prinzi niciun pește.
Da. Bineînțeles contează și ieșirea
la pescuit, mai ales după trei luni de
nepescuit în Delta Dunării, cel puțin
băieții de la noi de pe grup sunt fierți
să iasă. Le am trimis ier o poză și a
zis: „Bă, ce ne faci? Nu mi vine să cred
că noi n am ieșit la pescuit. Deci
contează și ieșirea, contează să stai,
contează cu cine mergi, contează cel
puțin pentru mine asta contează.
Contează să mă văd cu prietenii, să
discutăm despre pescuit, să bem o bere,
să, na, lucruri de genul ăsta și
contează și socializarea, nu doar
pescuită. Iar în perioada asta cred că
este punctul perfect mai mult de
socializare decât decât de a prinde
pește. Da, deci dacă prindem pește este
un bonus dacă prindem pește în perioada
asta. Eu am avut o partidă anul trecut
în martie, dar condițiile erau foarte
diferite.
A fost caldă pe 6 martie. Deci pe 6
martie am început să pescuiesc. Chiar mă
uitam că mi a mi a dat TikTok cu
notificare
cu amintire și am avut o super partidă
cu Marius Pengusta. Deci o super
partidă. Am prins pește din toate
pozițiile gusta acolo la intrare pe
partea stângă unde era pontonul. Nu știu
dacă mai este pontonul ăla acum acolo.
Dar cota era 60 la Tulcea. Da.
se deja fusese cald cu o săptămână
înainte, nu era ceață, adică condițiile
erau complet diferite și atunci
comportamentul peștelui era diferit. El
mergea pe prag, acolo unde pescuam eu pe
ngusta era o groapă sau încă este groapa
și noi pescuam efectiv pe pragul pe pe
peretele groapei. Da, deci nu pe
adâncime în groapă. Mi se pare că are 8
m groapa de acolo sau 9 m, nu știu
exact.
Nu pescuiam în groapă, pescuiam efectiv
pe peretele ei. Da, deci cum vine
groapa, îi dădeam undeva aici. Da. Și de
aici veneau trăsăturile. Deci peștii dar
peștii veneau veneau pe veneau pe
pe
peretele acela. Iar anul trecut
toată luna februarie nu a fost frig cum
a fost cum a fost anul ăsta. Da, cumva
peștele a început să se miște mai
devreme cam cred eu, preconizez eu că
dacă ține căldura cum a fost ieri alalte
și cum va fi și astăzi 12 14° cred eu că
într o săptămână, poate chiar două
peștele va începe să aibă comportamentul
ăla pe care l am văzut eu
anul trecut, dar na, momentan este în
comportament de iarnă. Momentan stă
cantonat pe ceate. Ce ceea ce
nu este rău dacă îi dai cu plumul în
cap. Bun.
Asta am vrut să zic. Sper că nu m am
lungit prea mult cu vorba. Cei care n
aveți răbdare sau știți deja
informațiile astea, dați și voi pe
înainte că na, stai mai dăm și
informații
pentru cei care nu le știu.
Deci este atât de frig. Mi au înghețat
mâinile
încât nici nu pot să mă așez jos. Că
efectiv simt că dacă mă așez jos îngheț
instant și stau în picioare și mă mișc
în barcă ca să mă încălzesc un pic.
Acuma începe să iasă un pic soarele și
văd că se ridică ceața. Dacă în 20 de
minute nu avem nicio trăsătură aici, o
să ne mutăm, o să ne ducem în altă
parte,
căutăm un alt canal să sperăm că acolo
găsim găsim peștele și că pot să mă
ancorez mai bine, să l pescuiesc mai
bine. [muzică]
Așa, gata. Acuma mcurat bine. Haideți să
vă arăt locul meu. Este foarte, foarte
interesant. Acolo în ciata din stânga
este căzută în apă și acolo de acolo
ieșeau peștii. Erau pești pe acolo. Se
plimbau și un pic pe lângă stuf din
partea stângă. Da. Deci hai să vedem.
Încerc acuma să lase să vedem care i
treaba.
[muzică]
Deci aici sunt peletele de 2 mm cu nada
ediție specială. Da. Nada care este
galbenă. Și asta este peleta care s a
topit și o s o schimb, deși ea mai
mergea acum un pic, dar totuși o s o
schimb.
O bag direct pe spin. Cârlic de 10.
Deci am spin.
Folosiți unghia ca să să băgați în
peletă, să înfigeți bine spinul.
Dacă nu puteți cu mână,
un lucru pe care nu vi l am spus sau l
am mai spus în clipuri este că Nada,
ediție specială
are în ea pelete galbene. Deci unde
vedeți unde vedeți galben mai deschis,
mai pronunțat, aici au fost pelete. Da.
Și
vă mai spun un
mic truc. Este și fluo. Este o nadă care
este un pic fluo, deci face un nor
destul de pronunțat în apă.
Prima trăsătură.
Încerc să l țin, să știți, pentru că am
niciodată acolo și nu vreau să se ducă
niciodată. Asta vrea să facă. Ia uitați
l.
H.
Primul pește, dragi pe scar pe
2026,
prima partidă. Hai să l și vedem.
Sper să l vedem.
Deci aici am peletă de
secret aroma.
Acuma pot să i dau un pil de fir că nu
mai am emoții.
Așa.
Să vedem pe unde l aducem.
Da, voi nu vedeți drillul de mine,
dar n am ce să fac.
Încerc să vedem dacă reușesc așa.
Nu știu. Frâna la un minută nu mai merge
bine.
Mamă, deci nu o să vă vină să credeți,
dar e măricel, dragi pescari. Ia să
vedem.
Oi de capul meu!
Ia uitați vă! Ia uitați vă, bă, cât e.
Mamă!
Mamă! Mamă! Mamă! Deci, no, imposibil!
Deci mi am luat iar capul de minciog ăla
mic la mine că am zis că prind ciortani
și ia uitați vă și voi.
Bine, mă.
Da. Deci nada pe momitor
cu peleta.
Ia uitați ce ne duce.
Haide, mă. Hai la poze, mă. Haide.
Haide. Hai, hai, hai, hai, hai la poze.
Haide, hai, hai.
Coadă de mincioc din nou. Îmi trebuia
una mai lungă.
Deci e un drill spectaculos, băieți.
Deja mă doare mâna.
Ia uitați vă și voi. Nici nu vreau să l
forțez tare pentru că v am zis am
cârlige de 10
și
bineînțeles singur în barcă e greu.
Sper doar că a obosit. A obosit el. Am
obosit și eu.
Haide, mă. Uite, trage barca. Îmi trage
cucii.
Uitați vă.
Și ați văzut trăsătura cum a fost? Da. N
a fost rana. S a lăsat așa un pic pe ea.
Probabil că intrat pe ran dacă îl lăsam
că era deja înțepat.
După cum vedeți, are destul de multă
forță și energie în el.
Deci nu sunt ca
nu sunt ca ăia din decembrie de pe
Litkov
când îi aduceam destul de ușor.
Haide, mă.
Deci efectiv nu obosește. Uitați vă și
voi la el. Pachet de mușchi. Pachet de
mușchi. Ăsta e.
E șu e lunguieț.
Sus, mă, acuma. Hai, hai sus. Hai sus
acum. Acum
n are loc în mincioc. Bă, băieți.
Huh! Vai de capul meu! Ia uitați vă, mă,
n are loc în minciog.
[râsete]
Canale, bă, băieților! Bă, ia uitați vă
și voi pe canale în Delta Dunării. Ce
facem cu Gda Fishing? Da,
nu mai pot. Deci nu mai pot, jur. M a
obosit peștele ăsta.
Nu știu cât are. Cred că are undeva la 6
7 kg. Cred că 7 kg. Nu am Nu am la mine
cântar, dar vă asigur eu că este mare.
[muzică]
Haideți să vă mai arăt ceva interesant
la nada. Ediție specială. Ea este
galbenă. Da, doar ce am pus nadă. Uitați
vă ce am pe mâini. Și acum o să mă spăl
pe mâini și n o să mi rămână colorant pe
mână. Da, o să vedeți că n o să mâna n o
să fie colorată imediat.
Nu m am spălat cu săpun. Da, ca să nu
ziceți că mi am dat cu săpun. Da. Și
uitați palma.
Bineînțeles că eu am mâinile crăpate, ne
a intrat un pic printre crăpături, dar
nu rămâne pe mâini. Situația stă în
felul următor. Au trecut
cred că aproximativ o oră și 20 de
minute. N am mai avut nicio trăsătură.
O să mi ies cu barca din nou. O să mă
uit acolo să văd dacă am pește. O să mă
duc un pic și pe la Harry să văd dacă și
el are pește pe acolo, că el este
ancorat pe o pe o altă cioată. Dacă nu
mai am pești acolo, mă duc în altă
parte.
Vă ziceam de fenomenul acela pe care l
am întâlnit pe Lidcov,
locul și peștele sau pe un loc scoți
maxim doi pești după care te ai mutat.
Și vreau să văd dacă aici s a întâmplat
lucrul ăsta, dacă peștii s au mutat de
acolo, dacă nu mai sunt acolo. Dacă sunt
acolo, în continuare o să revin.
Dacă nu, caut, caut alt loc. Hai la
treabă. M am întors pe același loc. Am
sondat.
M am uitat pe mai multe cioate, m am dus
și mai jos, m am dus și mai sus.
Am mai găsit pe o cioată pește și l am
lăsat pe Harry să să pescuiască acolo,
dar n a avut nicio trăsătură. Iar eu pe
ciata asta, în primă fază când m am dus
să mă uit, n am mai văzut niciun pește.
După care m am întors și am început să
văd câțiva pești. Ce se întâmplă? Ei
intră niciodată și ies foarte puțin. Nu
mai au același comportament pe care l au
avut mai devreme
prindă când am venit pe locul ăsta
înainte să l prind pe cel pe care l ați
văzut pe cameră ă cumva între timp a
început să bată și vântul. Nu știu cât
de mult ar cât de mult poate să
influențeze pe un astfel de canal
vântul, dar îmi lasă impresia că de când
a început să bată vântul, el parcă s a
retras mai mult pe cioată și stă băgat
în ciată. Acuma, na,
nu am unde să mă duc în altă parte. Deja
este ora 2:30, cred că e aproape de
3:00.
O să rămân aici. Peștele pe care l am
prins mai devreme, pentru că este un
pește mare pentru canale, mi a dat
speranțe că aș putea prinde și alții și
cumva mi am prelungit această vizită în
Delta Dunării cu o zi. Normal, trebuia
să plec astăzi la ora 2:00, dar am zis,
bă, na, dacă e să fie partida aia în
care prinzi pe canale Pești mari, mai
bine mai rămân o zi, ca să fiu sigur, să
nu mi pară rău după aia. Deci o să mai
stau până mâine. Mâine o să mai
pescuiesc până la ora 12:00 1, poate
maxim două și na, să vedem dacă scoatem
ceva. Dacă mai scoatem ceva
>> [muzică]
[muzică]
>> Deci ne am mutat de pe locul pe care am
pescuit astăzi toată ziua, unde l am
scos pe cel de 7 kg. Am venit pe un alt
canal, pe o cioată, am o cioată în față,
am sondat cioata. Este plină, este plin
de ciortan. Probabil toți sunt la fel ca
cel pe care l ați văzut mai devreme. Din
păcate, nu aveam microfonul pornit și n
am putute să auziți sunetul, dar vedeți
doar imaginea.
Am mai scos un pește. Să vedem acum dacă
mai intră ceva. Dacă nu, oricum sunt
super mulțumit până acum de de partida
mea.
Ia trăsătură, băieți.
Doiul a tras.
S a dus.
Stați un pic.
Am mai avut o trăsătură, Hari.
>> Am mai avut o trăsătură, dar nu l am
scos.
Cred că fac o greșeală că
și de
>> Dar vezi că nici la mine mie doar asta
îmi trage. Doar doiul mi a tras.
Nici eu nu cunosc bine locul.
Și acolo e ceva.
Acolo e, nu știu, ceva mai mic.
>> A îmbunătățit acum aici. Van are ceva
peste secretar.
>> Ce zice? Am încercat secretaroma anul
trecut. În martie mergea foarte bine.
Ești Van Ia, ia trăsătură stânga, stânga
trăsătură.
Stai să l înțep.
Este, tată. Este Hari.
Ia uite l. Stai să vă pun aici să vedeți
drillul. Vedeți că eu vorbesc și cu
camera. Da, ca să nu vă speriați.
Zice că pleacă acasă.
Deci, dragi pescari,
a treia trăsătură pe locul ăsta.
Se pare că
am avut noroc.
Frâna, frâna, frâna.
La fel ca ăla, Costeluș.
>> Bun. Și
>> poate un pic mai îmbrăcat, să zic.
Da,
e foarte bine. Ce ai?
Am venit.
>> Ia taci un pic. Harry cred că are peste
15.
Pe cuvântul meu.
Nou, Hari 2 J.
>> Bă, nu e, mă. Cred că are vreo trei. Ia
uite l.
>> Ia uitați, dragi pescari, așa pe pe apus
pe seară. Un crap cred că la vreo 3 kg
3,5.
Superb.
>> Da.
>> M trăieb.
Le înțep și după aia. Tot pe aia, cu
stele
a scăpat. Tocmai ce am mai avut o
trăsătură. Pe sfârșit de partidă mă
pregăteam să strâng. Vormeam cu băieții
că mai stau cinci minute și strâng. Și
am mai avut o trăsătură, dar l am simțit
pentru o secundă și s a eliberat. Mai
fac repede un lansău. Mai stau cinci
minute.
Gata, se lasă întunericul.
Se lasă și frigul. Mă apuc de strâns
astăzi, din punctul meu de vedere, într
o într o perioadă în care apa este rece,
am avut rezultate foarte bune. Am avut
trei pescoși
și două rateuri. Asta înseamnă, na, că
am avut la cârlig cinci pești, ceea ce
din punctul meu de vedere zic că este
perfect. Vedem ce mai facem și mâine
dimineață.
Dacă reușim să scoatem ceva pești. Nici
nu știu unde să mă duc mâine, dacă să
vin tot pe locul ăsta pentru că am avut
activitate din două ore cât am stat,
patru trăsături, ceea ce este foarte
bine. Sau să mă duc pe alte locuri.
Costel zicea să mă duc acolo unde am
văzut peștii mari, să încerc să mai scot
un pește mare. Poate reușesc să păcălesc
mâine, dar parcă aș vrea și un pic de
activitate. Nici nu știu. Vedem. Văd
mâine cum cum fac. Ce fac. Hai, ce să
zic? Seară bună și ne vedem dimineață.
Pa pa.
Neața, dragi pescari.
Doar ce am aruncat de cinci minute, mă
pregăteam, îmi pregăteam camerele și ce
credeți? Direct un drill.
Să vedem.
Un ciortănaș frumos.
Bun,
primul pește de astăzi. Deci, de cinci
minute l am aruncat. Pregăteam camera,
dădeam drumul la microfoane, chestii.
Când aud dintr o dată țâț ce se aude
când mă uit în spate
era un crap care trăgea.
Deci primul pește al partidei. Îl
eliberăm imediat.
Am început bine.
Bună dimineața, dragi pescari.
Este o dimineață friguroasă, la fel ca
ieri. Mi au înghețat mâinile, doar ce am
ajuns pe loc de 10 12 minute și după cum
ați văzut, am avut deja prima trăsătură,
un pește la cred că 1 kg, 1 kg și un
pic, un ciortan.
L am scos, l am eliberat și acuma sper
să mai vină și alții. Dau pe același loc
pe care am dat aseară, unde am avut o
frecvență foarte, foarte bună. În două
ore am avut cinci trăsături, trei
pescoși și doi doi scăpați.
Iar astăzi voi sta aici până la ora 2:00
1:00, hai să zic 1 2 pentru că după aia
trebuie să plec acasă. Trebuie să merg
la Tulcea să ridic barca. Na, mai sunt
lucruri de făcut și sper să scot și ceva
astăzi pe locul unde
am prins peștele cel mare de ieri
nici nu știu dacă să mă duc, dacă nu mă
duc. În principiu, dacă o să am
activitate aici, aici nu știu dacă o să
fie pești mai mari de 3 kg, asta i clar.
Cel de l ați văzut aseară, 3 kg, 3,5.
Și mă gândeam dacă cumva să mă duc pe
locul acela.
Poate dacă am o frecvență bună, o
activitate destul de intensă până la ora
11:00, să mă duc de la ora 11 pe locul
acela să văd dacă mai sunt peștii ăia
mari acolo și să încerc să i pescuiesc.
Dacă nu, rămân aici
pe activitate. Na, partida a început
promițător, dar
mi s a mai întâmplat mie așa de multe
ori.
Am lansat în primele 7 minute pește mare
de nu știu 7 kg, 6 kg, după care nimic.
Da, acum să sperăm că nu este cazul. Să
sperăm că o să am în continuare
trăsături și dacă nu, probabil o să mut
locul. Iar dacă nu, am trăsături nici
acolo. Oricum deja partida este super
reușită, din punctul meu de vedere. Hai
să vedem ce se mai întâmplă.
Dragi pescari, a mai venit în ciortan.
Deci a scăpat.
Este un pic de activitate. La o oră și
ceva a venit trăsătura. Am impresia că
eu sunt un pic greșit cu lansetele.
Ambele trăsături au venit de pe partea
stângă, deci mai din stânga. Ce o să fac
acum? O s o arunc pe asta și mai în
stânga și pe cea pe care o am în partea
stângă o s o dau și mai în stânga și o
să încerc să mă dau cu toate mai în
stânga. Să vedem, poate am mai multe
trăsături. V am zis, nu pot să mi iau
bine reperul aici. Malul pe malul opus
am
stuf și mi e greu să mi iau reperul, dar
na, încearc.
>> [muzică]
>> Am scos cele trei lansete din partea din
partea stângă. Le am dat un pic mai spre
stânga pentru că mi au venit mi au venit
trăsăturile,
cele două trăsături mi au venit pe
lansetele din partea stângă și le am
scos să le dau un pic mai în stânga. Am
lăsat una singură mai în dreapta. O s o
scot și pe ea când o să facă schimbul și
o s o dau și pe cea și pe ea tot în
partea stângă.
Băieți, de o oră și jumătate n am mai
avut nicio trăsătură pe locul ăsta. Am
avut peștele de dimineață pe care l am
scos. Am mai avut după aia o trăsătură
și l am scăpat. De atunci n am mai avut
nimic. În mod normal aș ieși cu sonarul
și m aș uita să văd dacă totuși peștele
mai este acolo și ce se întâmplă. Între
timp, a început să bată vântul. Ieri am
observat că la fel când a început să
bată vântul s au făcut valuri, nu a mai
tras peștele. Acum, na, este posibil să
fie legat de asta. Este posibil să nu
fie legat. Este doar o presupunere. Ce o
să fac acum, pentru că mai am doar patru
ore de pescuit, mă duc mă duc din nou pe
locul de pescuit unde am l am prins ieri
pe cel de 7 kg să văd dacă mai sunt alți
pești acolo la fel de mari și cumva să
zic risc așa pe ultimele pe ultima 100
de m în cazul în care na aș mai scoate
ceva, adică mi aș dori să mai scot ceva
mai mare. Bun, strâng sculele, mă duc
acolo și revin. Ne vedem Ne vedem de pe
locul acela.
Dragi pescari, asta a fost partida mea.
S a încheiat. Mai stau cinci minute și
plec. Îmi strâng un pic prin barcă și
după care o să mi strâng și lansetele. A
fost o partidă scurtă. A fost o partidă
care în primă fază trebuia să fie de 24
de ore, dar mai prelungit cu încă o zi
pentru că am prins scrapul ăla de 7 kg
și mi s a făcut așa o poftă de pescuit
de a sta mai mult. Am zis că o să mai
scot câțiva de șapte, dar n am scos de
șapte. Am scos pești mai mici. Dar
oricum a fost super frumos. Vremea a
fost super bună. Pești am văzut mulți pe
sonar și mă bucur foarte mult că am
văzut mulți pești pentru că asta
înseamnă că avem încă densitate de
pește.
Se anunță o primăvară bună, o primăvară
cu multe capturi și nu mai zic de vară,
vară în care sperăm să iasă și ăia mari
la poze. Cam asta a fost. Ați văzut cum
am pescuit. Același pescuit pe care îl
fac de fiecare dată pe canale cu
momitoare, cu cârlige mici, cu pelete de
10 în primăvară.
Când se mai încălzește un pic merg și
peletele de 15. Acuma de la de depinde
de la pescar la pescari. Stăteam mai
devreme cu băieții pe TikTok și le
spuneam că pescuiesc cu cădige de 10 și
erau așa mirați câțiva dintre de ei. De
10. Serios, de 10. Nu i cam mic
cârligul. Na, ăsta este pescuitul meu.
Este pescuitul pe care eu îl practic. Îi
vin din pescuitul la feeder, unde la
feeder se folosește foarte mult finețea
și atunci eu am aplicat lucrul acesta și
în Delta Dunări și se pare că dă și
rezultate de multe ori finețe.
Asta a fost partida. Ați văzut? Am
pescuit cu nadele de la noi din
portofoliu, de fapt cu nada. Nada ediție
specială. Am povestit toată tot clipul
despre ea pentru că, na, suntem în
perioada de promovare și atunci este
normal să facem lucrul acesta.
Acum când voi vedeți clipul și când eu
îl postez, avem o ofertă activă în care
dăm o pungă de nadă, ediție specială
pentru crap sălbatic la toate comenzile
care depășesc 100 RON la noi pe site.
Adică dacă cumperi de 100 RON mai
primești o pungă de nadă cadou. Da? Iar
mare atenție în această ofertă nu intră
bilele Delta Secret și Delta Activ. Știu
că sunteți sunt printre voi clienți care
au comandat Delta Secret și Delta Activ
și mi au scris că n au primit pungile de
nadă cadou. Îmi cer scuze pentru treaba
asta. Eu am specificat pe site, noi am
specificat pe site, am scris acolo că
bilele acestea nu intră în ofertă. Deci
doar aceste bile, doar bilele la
gălețile de 5 kg nu intră în ofertă. Dar
cei care au fost prea supărați, le am
trimis totuși pungile cadou că na, ca să
rămânem prieteni pentru că așa este
frumos. Da, deci oferta este încă
valabilă pe site la noi acum când postez
clipul. Eu îmi doresc să țin această
ofertă tot anul pentru că vreau să
promovez foarte bine nada aceasta, s o
dăm pescarilor să o pescuiască cu ea, s
o testeze.
Dacă nu va fi totanul acuma ne
înțelegeți și voi dacă nu va fi oferta
activă Totanul, dar în principiu în
prima parte până la închidere și la
deschiderea sezonului la până la
începerea prohibiției și la sfârșitul
prohibiției sigur va fi va fi activă.
Bun, dragilor,
asta a fost. Dacă vă plac clipurile
mele, dacă vă place ce fac aici, dacă
ați învățat lucruri noi, dacă
efectiv v a v am făcut să zâmbesc sau v
am făcut poftă de pescuit, am și o
rugăminte la voi. Lăsați și voi un
comentariu în care să scrieți absolut ce
vreți voi, pentru că ne ajută ca clipul
nostru să urce mai sus în vizualizări.
Să lăsați și un like, să dați și un
share către prieteni și așa mai departe.
Înțelegeți voi, pentru că majoritatea
care fac clipuri pe YouTube vă cer
lucrul ăsta și nu vă cer degeaba pentru
că fiecare vrea să se promoveze cât mai
bine. Da? Bine, dragi pescari, mulțumesc
frumos că v ați uitat până la sfârșit și
vă doresc fire întinse.